Transcription: Claire Ghyselen
Relecteur: eric vautier
Bonsoir et bienvenue à
« Questions pour un champion ».
Ce soir, nous accueillons Michel.
Bonsoir Michel.
Alors, vous venez de ?
Marié ?
Des enfants ?
Des passions ?
Des hobbies ?
Michel, êtes-vous prêt ?
Un indice s’affiche au bas de votre écran,
pour vous qui êtes chez vous.
Attention, top !
Issu des populations précarisées,
tant en milieu urbain que des campagnes,
je bénéficie de certaines
aides sociales d’État
ainsi que de ressources
liées à la petite délinquance.
Pratiqué de manière festive,
récréative ou abusive.
je conduis régulièrement une rupture
totale des liens familiaux et sociaux.
(Bip)
Top ! Fumeur, sniffeur, injecteur,
la diversité de mes pratiques
et consommations
font de moi un véritable
expert dans mon domaine.
Tantôt perchée, souvent fondée,
quelquefois en chien,
je jouis d’une mauvaise réputation
et mes concitoyens m’associent fréquemment
à de nombreux noms d’oiseaux.
Top ! VIH, SDF, LSA, CMU, sont les sigles
qui régissent mon quotidien,
quotidien qui débute généralement
vers 16 heures,
heure à laquelle je me lève pour assouvir
mon unique objectif
pour qui je serais prêt
à vendre père et mère,
voire ma Volvo Turbo dès 1995.
Je suis, je suis... (Bip)
Toxicomane !
Et c’est gagné ! Ouais !
(Musique de Question pour un champion)
Ça y est, il l’a dit, c’est bon ?
C’est pas trop tôt.
Ce n’est quand même pas compliqué
de dire qu’on est toxicomane,
qu’on est camé , drogué , toxico quoi.
Comment tu dis, toi ? Ah oui !
Usagers de drogues, ouais,
comme les mouchoirs usagés, quoi !
Ne croyez pas que c’est facile,
on ne devient pas toxico
du jour au lendemain.
Je ne suis pas né avec une seringue
d’argent dans la bouche, non, non !
C’est tout un parcours, ouais.
Première étape, ben,
il faut se droguer, quoi. Ouais.
Ça tombe bien
parce qu’il y a du choix, ouais.
Alors, cannabis, kétamine,
3MM-C, ecstasy, cannabis,
oh, je vais prendre de l’héroïne.
Bon, ben après, tu choisis
comment tu vas la prendre.
Par-là, en sniffant,
par-là , en fumant,
ou par-là, en injectant, quoi !
Ou les trois.
Après, tu deviens pas champion
des drogues en claquant des doigts.
Il faut bosser, quand même !
Il faut aller à l’école,
une école de commerce ?
Une école d’ingénieur,
l’école des Mines ?
Oui, tu sais,
pour étudier les marchés,
pour voir les meilleures stratégies
pour résoudre des vrais problèmes
d’ingénieurs.
Si un dealer part de Rotterdam
avec le train de 16h36,
avec en poche 6 kilos d’herbe,
à combien revend-il le gramme
en arrivant en gare de Nancy ?
Ou une fac de médecine, pour vraiment
savoir comment bien s’injecter
pour passer à l'acte.
Une fac de bio pour connaître
les molécules,
pour savoir ce qu’il ne faut pas
mélanger, quoi.
Une université de géographie aussi,
pour préparer son Erasmus,
savoir si tu vas partir à Katmandou,
au Maroc ou à la gare du Nord.
Et puis, bon, un petit conseil comme ça.
Moi, je conseille quand même de prendre
une option théâtre, pour financer tout ça.
T’aurais pas un euro ?
C’est tout un parcours
pour être un bon drogué, ouais.
Bon, après, ben si tu veux,
tu peux arrêter.
Tu peux passer à autre chose,
éventuellement rentrer dans le soin.
Moi, je préfère pas en parler,
Je laisse ça aux professionnels.
Et ça tombe bien, justement, aujourd’hui,
le professeur Gratin est là.
Ne bougez pas, je vais voir
s’il est OK pour...
Professeur, excusez-moi de vous déranger.
Est-ce possible que vous parliez
un petit peu de drogue là,
je n’ai pas l’impression
qu’ils comprennent grand-chose.
OK, super !
Vous allez voir, ils sont
hyper propres, OK.
(Avec l’accent allemand)
Guten tag à tous !
Avant toute chose,
quelques petites précisions.
Aujourd’hui, on ne parle plus de
toxicomanie, mais d’addiction.
Ja, le terme « drogue » est désuet.
Désormais, on parle des substances
psychoactives.
Et de la même façon,
on ne dit plus toxico, ja,
mais consommateur
de produits stupéfiants.
Car les mots ont une importance
capitale, ja.
Pour mieux comprendre, je vous propose
une petite expérience, ja.
Alors, disons que nous allons prendre une
substance illicite dérivée de la morphine,
qui va engendrer une dépendance
physique et psychologique.
L’héroïne.
J’en est justement toujours
un peu sur moi, on ne sait jamais, ja.
Première étape : le sevrage.
Nous allons faire disparaître,
ici, le produit.
Voilà qui est fait.
Je vais chercher bien évidemment
ma petite baguette magique.
Ja !
Attention ! Abracadabra !
Ha ! Ho ! Ja ! Et voilà !
Ha!
Il ne reste maintenant plus que
ce petit détail à régler, ja !
Vous allez voir,
c’est extrêmement simple, hop !
Je le mets dans la petite poche,
et voilà !
Ja !
Je la reprends, je la mets
dans la petite poche et voilà !
Ja, bon parfois, La dépendance
est bien installée,
mais pas de problème,
car on a de la substitution.
On va alors simplement remplacer
notre drogue par un médicament,
comme par exemple avec de la méthadone.
Oh, de la méthadone ! Ja !
Mais ça marche aussi
avec de la buprénorphine.
Oh !
De la buprénorphine.
Et ça marche aussi avec...
Bon, ça ne marche pas à tous les coups,
mais généralement, avec un peu de volonté,
ça finit toujours par disparaître.
C'est aussi simple que ça.
Non, malheureusement,
ce n’est pas aussi simple que ça.
Bonjour, je suis Benoit Boulet,
je suis éducateur spécialisé
et j’ai travaillé une quinzaine d’années
auprès des usagers de drogues.
Ça, c’est mon nez et ça,
c’est Michel Machin, mon clown.
C’est lui qui m’aide à parler de drogue.
Parce que non,
ce n’est pas simple de parler de drogue,
que l’on soit consommateur,
que l’on soit professionnel du soin
ou du médico-social,
ou qu’on soit dans l’entourage
proche d’un consommateur,
parents, amis, collègues.
Parce que non,
ce n’est pas simple de comprendre
toute la complexité de ce sujet.
La substitution, la dépendance,
les opiacés, les overdoses.
Et enfin parce que non,
il n’y a pas de baguette magique
pour en sortir facilement.
Alors oui, c’est un sujet
qui est compliqué à aborder
parce que ça touche tout le monde.
Parce que la drogue est partout.
Et elle n’est pas près de disparaître.
Et parce que ça fait peur.
Et de ce fait, les consommateurs
n’ont pas bonne presse,
ils n’ont pas une belle image,
ni une bonne réputation.
D’ailleurs, vous n’entendrez jamais :
(Voix aiguë) «Bonjour,
je m’appelle Michèle,
je suis toxicomane
et j’habite au troisième étage.
vous venez prendre un petit café ?»
Non, non, ça ne se passe pas comme ça.
Demandez plutôt à Michel
comment ça se passe.
Michel qui, pour obtenir des seringues
stériles, était obligé de prétexter
auprès du pharmacien
de sa petite ville de campagne
qu’il en avait besoin pour pouvoir
nourrir son petit hamster malade.
Ou encore Michel,
qui n’arrivait pas à dire à son épouse
qu’il avait repris des injections.
Chaque jour, il portait des T-shirt à
manches longues pour cacher ses bras.
Et chaque matin, avant d’aller au travail,
il s’injectait dans sa voiture,
avec la même seringue depuis des semaines,
seringue qu’il avait récupérée
discrètement
auprès d’une association
de réduction des risques.
Ou encore Michel.
Michel qui, suite à un passage compliqué
au service des urgences,
a préféré taire
son problème d’abcès à la main.
Problème d’abcès qui le conduira
un an plus tard dans le même service
pour se faire amputer de l’avant-bras.
Attention,
tous les Michel Machin ne vivent pas mal
leur consommation de drogue,
on est d’accord.
Mais des Michel Michin en souffrance,
il y en a des centaines.
Il y en a des milliers
et il y en a même plus,
parce que le business
de la drogue est énorme.
Et ce qui est énorme aussi,
c’est tous les ravages que ça va engendrer
auprès des consommateurs
et de leur entourage.
Heureusement,
plein de dispositifs existent,
comme par exemple les CAARUD,
les centres d’accueil et d’accompagnement
à la réduction des risques
pour les usagers de drogues.
CAARUD, ouais, le terme
n’est pas super approprié,
mais c’est vrai que dans l’urgence
de créer ce type de dispositif,
on n’a pas fait attention
à l’acronyme un peu douteux.
Et pourtant, ces centres de première ligne
sont extrêmement précieux
pour tous nos Michel Machin.
un accueil anonyme, gratuit,
sans jugement,
où ils vont pouvoir venir parler de
leur situation et de leur consommation.
Et ça, c'est essentiel.
C’est essentiel parce qu’en matière
de réduction des risques,
on fait le constat que
plus les consommations sont cachées,
plus elles sont risquées
et que moins on en parle,
et plus les risques augmentent.
C’est donc essentiel de parler,
et d’en parler.
Ha, ben tiens !
C’est justement là que
Michel Machin intervient.
Mon clown va m'aider à parler de drogue.
Comment ?
En fait, ce nez va me permettre
de rentrer en contact.
Parce que le rire,
c’est un langage universel.
Ce nez va me permettre de dire les choses
d’une manière détournée,
de traduire, de vulgariser,
de dédiaboliser le sujet.
Et puis, enfin, ce nez va
me permettre de tout dire.
Et surtout, il me protège.
Il me protège face au tragique.
Et moi, ce tragique, j’ai décidé d’en rire
pour qu’il soit moins tragique.
Alors je sais, vous allez me dire que
c’est quand même fou d’utiliser
la figure du clown pour parler
d’un sujet comme ça.
Mais alors, comment parler
d’un sujet sensible ?
Comment parler d’un sujet qui fâche ?
C’est ça, la question !
Car si on ne met pas les mots,
si on ne parle pas,
on marginalise le problème.
On rend les gens victimes,
on exclut, on crée de la violence,
de l’inégalité, de l’injustice.
Alors parlons ! Parlons-en !
Parlons des drogues !
Le cannabis ?
Le cannabis, c’est la drogue en Europe
qui est la plus consommée.
Des millions de consommateurs en Espagne,
des millions de consommateurs en Italie
et pas qu’à l’Eurovision.
Et vous savez quoi ? En France,
on est dans les premiers.
Ouais, et pourtant, le débat
sur la légalisation
ou même simplement la dépénalisation,
n’avance pas depuis des années.
Et c’est pareil pour les S. C. M. R. :
les salles de consommation
à moindre risque.
Je suis sûr que vous connaissez.
Les salles de shoot.
Vous voyez l’importance des mots ?
2016 : ouverture de la première
salle en France, à Paris.
Actuellement, il y en a deux,
avec celle de Strasbourg.
Toutes deux ouvertes dans le cadre
d’une phase d’expérimentation de 6 ans.
En Europe,
il y en a presque une centaine.
31 au Pays-Bas, 24 en Allemagne,
13 en Espagne,
il y en a même deux au Luxembourg,
12 en Suisse.
C’est d’ailleurs en Suisse
que la première salle fut ouverte.
C’était à Berne,
en 1986.
J'avais 6 ans.
86, c’est aussi l’année de Tchernobyl,
mais je vous rassure,
ça n’a aucun rapport.
Et vous savez quoi ?
Il y a même des pays qui envisagent
d'ouvrir des salles dans les prisons.
Dans les prisons - je vous rappelle
qu’il n’y a pas de drogue en prison.
Je vous rappelle qu'il n'y a pas de
consommation de drogue en prison.
Non, il n'y a pas de contamination
à l'hépatite C en prison.
Non, n'en parlons pas.
Surtout, ne parlons pas non plus
de la consommation de drogue
chez les mineurs isolés à Paris
et encore moins de la consommation de
drogue dans le milieu de la prostitution.
Non, n’en parlons pas et de toute façon,
je crois qu’on n’a plus le temps.
Alors oui !
J'utilise le clown pour parler
de drogue, c'est mon outil,
mon moyen de communication.
C’est en tout cas ce que j’ai trouvé
pour aborder ce sujet.
Est-ce que ça marche ?
Ben ouais, ça marche.
Ça interpelle, ça fait réagir,
ça fait réfléchir, ça bouscule
et aujourd’hui, j’espère que
Michel Machin vous aura bousculé.
Parce qu’effectivement,
il n’est pas toujours tendre.
Mais de ne pas en parler,
est-ce que c’est mieux ?
Il y a des sujets qui méritent
d'être bousculés.
Et vous ?
Vous en avez des sujets qui fâchent ?
Alors, trouvez la façon d’en parler
et agissez !
Merci.
(Applaudissements)